anita de demain itinéraire bis dimanche
à 10h45 sur public sénat
bonjour et bienvenue à bruxelles au
coeur du parlement européen pour ce
nouveau numéro de rente et de dos et sur
ce plateau dans quelques instants nous
allons parler du dumping social on
connaît le phénomène des plombiers
polonais mais il ya aussi des chauffeurs
routiers polonais ils sont très nombreux
sur les routes de notre continent
reportage dans un instant mais d'abord
l'actualité les européens et le fonds
monétaire international ont volé au
secours de la grèce qui était une fois
de plus au bord du gouffre mais cette
aide va t'elle suffire c'est la question
de la semaine la grèce attendait depuis
six mois l'aide promise par ses
partenaires
asphyxiée par sa dette elle a besoin
d'argent frais pour payer ses
fonctionnaires ses retraités et faire
tourner l'économie
les réunions se succèdent à bruxelles en
vain les bailleurs de fonds d'athènes
échoue à régler le casse-tête grec
laissant le pays au bord de la faillite
et puis le 26 novembre les créanciers de
la grèce reviennent au chevet du malade
treize heures de discussions intenses
difficile et au bout de la nuit surprise
un accord est conclu les ministres de la
zone euro et les représentants du fonds
monétaire international estiment que le
pays qui a fait voter un nouveau plan de
rigueur remplit les conditions pour le
versement d'une aide language on a
énormément travaillé
nous nous sommes vu trois fois et
pendant deux nuits
oui des doutes mais nous l'avons fait et
aujourd'hui c'est un bon jour pour les
membres de l'eurozone
mission accomplie peter tschopp la dette
grecque sera ramené à 124 % du produit
intérieur brut d'ici 2020 ce qui fait un
allègement de 40 milliards d'euros
athènes recevra aussi 43 milliards
d'euros dead en plusieurs tranches
elle aura aussi plus de temps pour
rembourser sa dette une fois de plus les
européens ont volé au secours de leurs
partenaires mais dans six mois le pays
se retrouvera peut-être encore à court
d'argent parce que sa dette aura
augmenté et que les caisses seront vides
alors à quoi bon aider la grèce
voilà alors cette semaine le regard d'un
député britannique sur l'actualité
européenne graham watson bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le président du parti des
libéraux et démocrates pour l'europe
donc européen convaincu et très
impliquée ici au parlement européen on a
entendu le ministre français de
l'économie et des finances pierre
moscovici qui s'exprime et d'ailleurs en
anglais il estime que ce qui s'est passé
récemment à l'eurogroupe est un tournant
pour la crise grecque
est ce que vous partagez son sentiment
oui je partage cette idée il c'est vrai
que beaucoup mettent en question le coup
de sauver la grèce mais le coup de ne
pas sauver la grèce pourrait être
beaucoup plus haut nous sommes dans une
position où les allemands en premier
lieu mais tout le monde a décidé que la
grèce doit rester au sein de l'euro les
grecs même on trouvait la discipline
pour faire ce qu'il faut et donc nous
irons de ce point là pour l'avenir mais
c'est vrai que sur ce même plateau il ya
quelques mois on se disait la même chose
on disait la grèce est au bord du
gouffre il faut à nouveau donner de
l'argent
les européens données delà de l'argent
en impression que c'est jamais suffisant
est ce que cette fois-là la somme donnée
l'allègement de dette consentis
des taux d'intérêt plus ou parce que
toutes ces mesures là vraiment suffire à
ce que vaut vraiment suffire pour
qu'athènes puisse se relever
je pense qu'ils doivent suffire nous
avons maintenant aussi l'expérience que
porte le fmi dans ces choses là et je
pense que nous avons un plan qui va
remettre la grèce sur la bonne voie mais
s'il ya une différence
une grande différence entre la situation
actuelle et la situation d'ici un an
enfin il y a un an c'est que la
détermination politique en europe existe
ce qui n'était pas tout à fait le cas il
ya un an et l'allemagne n'était pas
forcément très partante pour aider la
grèce
finalement le fait que l'allemagne est
accepté d'aider les grecs a raconté
c'est difficile parce que à la fin c'est
eux qui ont la capacité de sauver la
grèce mais évidemment ils doivent
confronter aussi leurs électeurs je
trouve qu'ils ont fait leur la bonne le
bon choix et j'espère qu'un gouvernement
allemand aura la reconnaissance aux
urnes pour ce qui a été fait est ce que
vous pensez que les grecs ont fait
assez d'effort est ce que les
changements donc on attendait d'athènes
on se sont se sont fait par exemple sur
le front de la corruption notamment
je pense que ce que fait le gouvernement
actuel en grèce ce sont des mesures très
important pour lutter contre la
corruption
pour bien prendre les impôts que les
gens ne paient pas dans le passé ils ont
fait une série de rohff réforme aussi de
réduire les coûts de l'état où elles
faire en grèce reste à voir si les grecs
supporte les mesures qui vont être mises
en place
et si la grèce ne les supporte pas il ne
s'agit pas de rester ou ne pas rester au
sein de l'euro mais plutôt de rester où
nous paraissait au sein de l'union
européenne
et pour vous c'est la seule
voie possible continuer à être solidaire
d'athènes même s'il faut à chaque fois
donné de plus en plus d'argent pour
aider la grèce que c'est la seule
solution pour que la la zone euro
survive
nous sommes solidaires avec lisbonne
nous sommes solidaires avec dublin
nous sommes solidaires avec madrid avec
nico cia il faut être solidaire aussi
avec athènes la grèce fait partie de
l'union européenne et on veut que ceci
reste le cas alors on va ouvrir une page
de plus international on va rejoindre
dans un instant un collègue qui nous
parlera spécifiquement de la situation
au mali moi je voulais vous interroger
sur la palestine puisque il ya une
réunion importante qui se décident en ce
moment à l'onu au sujet de du statut du
fameux statut de l'état palestinien
la france a dit qu'elle reconnaîtrait
les européens sont la position
européenne est plus floue vous-même que
dites vous est ce que la palestine doit
devenir le 194e état nations unies je
pense que la position de la france qui
est d'ailleurs la même que la position
du parlement européen qui a voté la
semaine dernière c'est que la palestine
doit être reconnu par l'onu comme un
état ce ne sera pas un état membre des
nations unies comme d'autres mais
l'important c'est que ceux qui étaient
contenues dans les résolutions du
conseil de sécurité 242 et les autres
soient reconnus officiellement par
l'assemblée dans l'assemblée de l'onu
en tout cas au moins elle aura un statut
ce qui n'est pas le cas actuellement
l on me lançait que c'est ce sera ça va
compter ce sera uniquement symbolique
nous sommes dans une position
extrêmement difficile au proche orient
est d'abord puisque les israéliens ont
d'un gouvernement qui est assez extrêmes
les américains
n'interviennent pas comme ils sont
intervenus dans le passé pour retendre
les actions de l'israël il faut que les
européennes jouent un rôle plus
important et donc la reconnaissance du
palestine fait partie d'une approche
globale beaucoup plus forte de l'union
bel et bien on suivra cette question
merci beaucoup graham watson d'avoir été
avec nous sur le plateau devant et dos
tout de suite donc le zapping des télés
européennes avec un focus sur la
situation au mali c'est dans cette
commune rurale de diéma la frontière
avec la mauritanie que l'enlèvement
s'est produit ce ressortissant français
a franchi hier vers 11 heures le poste
frontière de gogui il venait de
s'arrêter dans une radio locale de diéma
pour se connecter à internet quand il a
été enlevé par plusieurs hommes armés
il y à une intervention militaire qui se
prépare donc pour eux des terroristes
capturé un otage c'est un moyen de faire
pression
on ne la pensait pas possible avant au
moins plusieurs mois mais l'intervention
militaire au mali ne serait plus qu'une
question de semaines
selon le ministre français de la défense
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
a donné mandat au pays d'afrique de
l'ouest de s'organiser pour qu'il y ait
une intervention afin de rétablir la
souveraineté du navire qui
officiellement on joue encore la carte
de la diplomatie mais sur le terrain les
grandes manoeuvres ont déjà commencé
pour reconquérir le nord du mali une
région grande comme 20 fois la suisse
sous le contrôle de mouvances islamistes
qui ont fait voler l'unité du mali en
éclats et instaurer la charia à gao et
tombouctou
la perle du désert cette offensive
islamiste n'est pas nouvelle au
contraire afrique de l'ouest 1836 oumar
tall chef de l'état guerrière des
toucouleurs rentre d'un pèlerinage à la
mecque et d'un séjour à l'université
coranique al azhar du caire
sa décision est prise il va lancer un
jihad il lève alors une armée de 30000
hommes avec laquelle il se taille un
empire dans l'actuel mali voilà pour ce
petit tour d'horizon un nouvel invité
avec nous nicolas gros verheyde bonjour
bonjour vous êtes correspondant à
bruxelles pour ouest france et vous
tenez un blog sur la défense européenne
vous êtes bien renseigné sur ce qui se
passe ce qui se prépare en tout cas au
mali une opération pour libérer le nord
du pays de l'emprise de groupe
djihadiste armé
on va pas rentrer dans les détails mais
dites-nous en quelques mots quelle sera
la participation des européens à ce
dispositif
il faut bien voir qu'il ya trois
opérations en une il faut il ya quand
même trois opérations distinctes la
participation des européens va se
concentrer sur le renforcement la la
restructuration la remise sur pied de
l'armée malienne avec des formateurs
environ 250 militaires qui vont partir à
bamako et aux environs pour aller
refermer l'armée malienne et la
restructurer un peu ce qu'ont fait les
européens en ouganda avec l'armée
somalienne est quelque chose qui se
poursuit qu'il ya eu un certain succès
c'est une mission d'accompagnement
c'est une mission j'irai on va dire de
coopération militaire c'est le lea
solitaire assez classique finalement
très classique et les européens vont pas
la baptiser comme ça mais c'est c'est
uniquement comme ça il y aura pas que
les européens normalement il pourrait y
avoir d'autres d'autres pays non
européens les canadiens auraient été
approchés ils pourraient aussi
participer parce qu'ils ont été très
présents au mali la deuxième opération
c'est celle de la cedeao donc des pays
africains d'afrique de l'ouest avec
d'autres pays qui lave à venir j'irai
d'abord sécuriser le sud est ensuite
remonté éventuellement est remonté sur
le nord donc là les européens en tant
qu'entité ne vont pas fournir dead mais
chacun des pays
effectivement fournir un appui
logistique de renseignement transport
aérien il est évident qu préparation ne
peut pas se monter comme ça tout seul
pour qu'on comprenne n'y aura pas de
soldats européens aura pas de l'aura pas
ses soldats au combat
il y aura mathématiquement il faut bien
des des militaires au sol pour guider et
pour assurer
rien que pour aussi du transport
stratégique il faut bien que les avions
atterrissent que ces missions
logistiques mais là on a une mission
logistique direct d'accompagnement assez
lourde et sans doute avec des des forces
spéciales des forces de renseignement et
les africains n'ont pas de soleil et une
liste donnée par la cedeao aux
différents alliés il ya l'onu
officiellement et donc les différents
pays de l'onu vont s'habiller et ensuite
il ya un dialogue politique assez gérer
musclé qui va essayer des pressions qui
vont essayer d'amener les mouvements
rebelles
à ceux-ci sio nez et à ceux à s'asseoir
à la table de nadège adam ashton la
haute représentante ce dialogue enfin
c'est ce qu'elle participe à cette
opération pas du tout ce qui est un
dialogue qui s'instaure
pour l'instant l'europe réfléchisse à
son problème elle est quand même en
retard d'une guerre elle a réfléchi à la
nomination d'un représentant spécial aux
eaux celles qui en fait serait à même de
mener ces négociations faut savoir qu'il
ya des gens entre guillements européen
qui est nommé représentant spécial au
nom de l'onu qui romano prodi qui va
d'une certaine façon est effectué cette
combinaison là et bien merci nicolas
gros verheyde pour cet éclairage est
claire je renvoie sur votre blog
bruxelles 2 pour plus d'informations et
on retrouve tout de suite françois baud
données sont invités après ce reportage
inédit sur une pratique douteuse de plus
en plus de sociétés belges ou françaises
embauche des chauffeurs routiers venus
de certains pays de l'est et cela à très
bas prix et dans des conditions
dangereuses pour la sécurité routière
c'est une enquête signée ilana azencott
et yoann là
une autoroute au sud de la belgique
la pluie toujours la pluie grégory 53
ans a passé plus de la moitié de sa vie
ici dans la cabine de son camion
ainsi lionel europe jusqu'au
moyen-orient
ce soir là pourtant la mission de ce
chauffeur indépendant m'a plus grand
chose d'exotique une cinquantaine de
kilomètres à peine entre liège et namur
fatah je partais les vrais élus les mais
j'ai fait un ramassage des oeufs
ça peut faire tourner autour d'eux les
visuels à ajoie il y a quatre ans
grégory était à la tête d'une entreprise
florissante cinq personnes travaillaient
pour lui aujourd'hui
ce patron n'a même plus de quoi se
verser un salaire de chauffeurs son
avenir s'écrit comme les lignes de la
route en pointillés c'est plus possible
parce que les réponses annuelle actuelle
c'est bon ben si vous ne faites pas ça
lituaniens ou un slovaque ou à tchèque
ou apollo micro fait j'ai envie
d'arrêter
j'ai envie de tout de tout plaquer c'est
un métier que j'adore je serais rien
faire d'autre mais je suis dégoûtée je
suis dégoûtée sur fond d'ouverture des
frontières et de libéralisation des
transports la chute a été brutale
ce soir là les concurrents de grégory ne
dorme qu'à quelques mètres à la lisière
de l'autoroute 15 camions neufs qui sont
immatriculés dans les pays de l'est y
avait un fils une tête une fois dans
l'ouest la danse était une fois dans
l'est
drôle de western
si cette main d'oeuvre low cost est venu
par la route
c'est à proximité du plus grand port du
pays qu'elle a trouvé refuge sur les
docks d'anvers ce jour là
des centaines de chauffeurs attentes da
l'abri des regards leurs marchandises
ici les journalistes ne sont pas les
bienvenus
c'est en caméra cachée que nous allons à
leur rencontre là c'est les tchèques
l'ukraine et les slovaques sont ici à
gauche
une de ces polonais de poznan s'apprête
à passer à table à l'arrière d'un camion
sur le parking pas de cuisine seulement
trois wc et de douches pour plus de 500
personnes
on dort dans le camion on mange dans le
camion faut se battre pour les toilettes
oui c'est difficile difficile et
quelques minutes plus tard une autre
question plus embarrassante encore vous
attendez ici depuis longtemps
cette semaine quatre au non dit pas ça
ah bon il a trois jours mieux vaut
mentir car rester quatre semaines c'est
illégal
un chauffeur étrangers à sept jours pour
quitter le pays mais sans gps facile de
tricher un peu plus loin
ce chauffeur roumain a lui aussi dépassé
le délai son salaire de base
150 euros 19h06 c'est pas un salaire
fixe
vous êtes payés au kilomètre oui c'est
pas correct
ma compagnie fait de gros profits sur
notre taux des primes au kilomètre
autant dire une incitation à rouler là
encore la législation plafonne la
conduite à 10 heures par jour mais pour
espérer gagner plus beaucoup de
conducteurs de l'est falsifient les
données de leurs compteurs électroniques
difficile de prendre la mesure des
fraudes
seule certitude pour ces travailleurs
précaires l'histoire va parfois beaucoup
plus loin sur ses terres de repos il y a
deux ans presque jour pour jour ce
permanent syndical de la fgtb équivalent
belge de la cgt a dû intervenir pour
régler une situation sans précédent
propre leur convoi que tous les
chauffeurs qui sont en majorité des
slovaques sur cet hebdo c'est seulement
ça fait trois mois que n'ont pas été
payés
on leur demande on leur demande de
descendre de leur camion une vingtaine
de slovaques tombé du camion et très
vite pour philippe dumortier une autre
surprise derrière leur société un
employé en berne
le représentant légal donc à monsieur
david faux clé avec la salaire mensuel
427 euros des sociétés belges auraient
tel recours à ce dumping
c'est le début d'une longue enquête
fait unique en europe début 2012 le
syndicat se rend à bratislava
équipé d'une caméra cachée cet homme se
fait passer pour un employeur souhaitant
en implanter une société fictive
c'est un tout petit bâtiment il ya 250
sociétés à l'intérieur donc fait c'est
illogique parce qu'il ya pas de 150
bureaux dans ce type de bateau non
l'accord n'a par contre il ya toute une
série de boîtes aux lettres juste
derrière la porte vitrée et le nombre de
boîtes aux lettres est assez
impressionnant
pour alain durand la pêche est
miraculeuse sur les murs de boîtes aux
lettres des centaines de filiales
fictive de société bien réel venu faire
le plein de travailleurs dans un pays à
la fiscalité avantageuse
c'est illégal étant donné que la société
n'est pas dirigée depuis le pays qui a
aucun camion sur le territoire mohawk
certainement un point capital un article
capital qui donnerait la possibilité à
pays membres de la communauté européenne
de porter plainte sur notre état
problème de moyens ou de volonté
politique
malgré l'entorse directive européenne
mais poursuit tu resteras dans un an
les syndicats redoutent même une
nouvelle déréglementation des transports
une aubaine pour les grands groupes
synonyme de disparition pour les plus
fragiles
voilà pour cette enquête édifiante signé
yoan or la pervenche berès bonjour
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne
française vous êtes socialiste quand on
voit ce qu'on vient de voir dans ce
reportage des chauffeurs de l'est de
l'europe qui sont payés 500 euros par
mois
est-ce que c'est pas ce genre de
phénomène qui participent de manque de
popularité de l'europe est ce qu en
clair c'est pas ça qui va brouiller
l'image de l'europe mais vous avez
totalement raison
et ce dossier des transporteurs routiers
leur temps de travail c'est le premier
dossier dont j'ai eu à me saisir lorsque
j'ai été élu président de la commission
des affaires sociales en 2009
or derrière tout ça il ya la question de
savoir comment est ce que les états
membres acceptent de progresser en
matière de lutte contre le dumping
social c'est aussi un débat entre états
membres
mais n'oublions pas que derrière il ya
parfois me semble-t-il la question de
savoir si c'est une majorité
progressiste ou pas qui est aux
responsabilités donc je voudrais pas que
lorsque nous aurons un rendez vous en
eh bien on brouille les cartes si nous
voulons avancer dans ce sens là eh bien
nous avons aussi besoin d'avoir une
majorité plus progressistes sur
parlement et les citoyens européens qui
regardent ce reportage et qui
connaissent la réalité parce que c'est
un phénomène dans le jir routier mais on
le voit aussi dans le bâtiment on le
voit aussi dans le nettoyage
il ya énormément de secteurs c'est comme
ça mais qu'est ce que vous dites est ce
que c'est je dirais la faute de l'europe
ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui
en tout cas c'est une c'est parce qu'il
manque un outil dans la construction
européenne qui est tous bien toute la
question de la dimension sociale s'est
pas assez d'europe et son contraire
c'est trop d'europe et bien sûr que
c'est pas assez d'europe parce que
lorsqu'on a fait l'élargissement
nous on est ouvert les frontières les
routes ça paraît normal on ne peut pas
devoir faire l'élargissement et remettre
des frontières à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne c'est totalement contraire à
toute l'idée de l'union européenne y
compris dans la circulation des
personnes
mais derrière ça veut dire qu'il faut
prouver
l'harmonisation sociale en 2002 il y à
une législation qui rentrait qui a été
élaborée qui est entré en vigueur en
2009 qui prévoit de contrôler dans le
domaine des transporteurs routiers ce
qu'on appelle les indépendants or cette
législation
la commission voulue la corriger pour
exclure les indépendants du champ
d'application de cette directive et le
parlement refuse et cela ça a été une
victoire très importante mais la
difficulté c'est que la commission ne
sanctionne pas les états membres qui ne
contrôle pas si je me permets de vous
faites de la cuisine interne européenne
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut dire à ses
chauffeurs routiers c'est indépendant il
y avait un chauffeurs routiers
indépendants qui sont en train de perdre
leur travail à toute une filière
par exemple en france mais aussi en
belgique qui est en train de disparaître
parce que justement il ya une invasion à
leur terme est un peu est un peu barbare
mais en tout cas de ses chauffeurs
routiers venus laisse qu'est ce qu'on
peut leur dire est ce que les choses
avancent et ce qu'ils vont être protégés
ou est-ce que c'est fini pour eux en
tout cas je peux vous dire que ici nous
nous battons mais nous ne sommes pas
toujours majoritaire pour le faire donc
c'est bien une question politique il
faut transformer la donne et permettre
que ceux qui sont en faveur de davantage
d'harmonisation sociale soit majoritaire
au parlement européen à la commission je
m'excuse c'est notre cuisine de
gouvernance mais c'est le rapport de
force qui permettra d'avancer sur ces
questions là ce que vous avez monté dans
le reportage c'est très significatif
ce sont aussi des sociétés belges
françaises ou autres qui ont développé
des filiales dans ces pays pour
bénéficier des conditions sociales et
fiscales de recrutement de faux
indépendants qui viennent ensuite faire
concurrence aux travailleurs dans ce que
vous le dites c'est que c'est un peu
facile de jeter la pierre sur les pays
de l'est de l'est de l'europe mais qu'il
ya ici de ce côté de l'europe des gens
qui on profite lui bien sûr lorsque une
société belge française multiplie les
filiales en slovaquie ou en pologne pour
pouvoir recruter les personnes sur place
aux conditions de travail sur place
c'est bien une condition qui contribuent
à ce domaine
est ce qu'elles ont choix si elles ne
font pas de toute façon
on peut dire que d'autres le feront et
est-ce qu'elles ont le choix réellement
le choix on l'a toujours la question
c'est de savoir comment est ce qu'on se
bat ensuite pour harmoniser les
conditions
c'est important pour eux en termes de
concurrence c'est aussi majeures en
termes de condition sociale ça vous avez
vu les conditions de vie de ces gens on
peut pas considérer ces chauffeurs
routiers ne peut pas considérer que ce
soit digne d'un modèle social européen
mais c'est aussi une question de
sécurité routière parce que ces
chauffeurs dans ces conditions de
travail sur les routes doivent faire
2002 m absolument alors on va regarder
écouter une question qui est posée
justement à votre attention par ce
syndicaliste belge
et puis ensuite on revient avec vous en
l'écoutant le règlement qui régit la
plantation d'une société de transport
dans un pays membre de la communauté
européenne stipule certaines choses et
notamment que la société doit disposer
dans ce même pays d'un bâtiment
administratif et d'un bâtiment technique
or ce que nous avons constaté à
bratislava lors de notre expédition
début 2012
c'est tout simplement que ces sociétés
n'existe pas où elles existent
uniquement sur papier que compter que
comptez vous faire pour résorber ce
problème l'un pour anéantir tout
simplement la fraude fiscale et la
fraude sociale qui est organisé alors
qu'avant je verrai ce quelle est votre
réponse
c'est une très bonne question parce que
c'est ce qu'on appelle la pratique des
sociétés boîte à lettres c'est à dire
une coquille vide
pour cela il faut à la fois je vous le
disais que la commission européenne
lutte contre les faux indépendants
qu'elle oblige les états membres à
contrôler ce qui se passe dans le
secteur des transports comme dans
d'autres secteurs par exemple dans le
secteur de la construction où ce type de
phénomène existe aussi
il faut que la chaîne de responsabilités
soient définies parce qu'aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il ya ses filiales ses sociétés
boîte à lettres et bien bien souvent la
société mère ne s'occupe pas de ce qui
se passe dans la filiale
il faut qu'elle soit responsable aussi
des conditions d'application de la
législation
et puis il faut une progression pour que
la question des conditions de travail de
durée de travail puisse être mieux
harmoniser au niveau européen faut
savoir que propositions que nous avons
rejeté prévoyait par exemple des
indépendants puissent travailler donc
officiellement entre 84 voir donc vous
pouvez travailler 84 voire 80 6 heures
par semaine alors quelle est la limite
entre la légalité et l'illégalité ces
compagnies qui font ça qui font
travailler des chauffeurs alors on
disait polonais mais ces slovaques aussi
également est ce qu'elles sont dans la
légalité ou est ce qu elles sont
carrément dans l'illégalité
manifestement quand on voit les
conditions de vie de ces chauffeurs
routiers ne peut pas considérer que ce
soit la légalité mais c'est vrai qu'il y
a des failles dans le degré
d'harmonisation sociale qui est tourner
le sait beaucoup beaucoup développée que
la libre circulation des biens et des
marchandises qui conduisent à ces
situations où de telles failles peuvent
peuvent peuvent se développer alors ce
sont des failles qui sont liées à la
législation européenne
en revanche ce qu'on voit c'est ya pas
de contrôle en tout cas pas assez et ses
contrôles dans le monde doivent être
faits par les états membres dans quand
l'audience par la france ou par la
belgique pourquoi est ce que ces états
membres ne le font pas parce que d'une
certaine manière il ya une complicité ou
nous protègent leur secteur national et
c'est là où je pense que la commission a
aussi une responsabilité attendait
vraiment j'aimerais comprendre le fait
de ne pas contrôler
les chauffeurs routiers slovaques ou
polonais en france c'est pour protéger
le secteur national
non c'est un espèce de deux il ya des
contrôles qui sont exercées et vous
aussi savoir que dans les conditions du
gard budgétaire ces contrôles sont
chères sont parfois difficiles à
organiser créer des climats de tension
sur les lieux de circulation de
confrontation entre chauffeurs on l'a
très bien vu dans votre reportage qui
rendent les choses difficiles mais ici
au niveau du parlement repères moi ce
que je constate aussi c'est que la
commission européenne ne développe pas
les outils qu'elle a vis-à-vis des états
membres qui n'appliquent pas bien la
législation notamment le fait que les
indépendants doivent être couverts par
la législation en matière de temps de
travail
le message est envoyé à josé manuel
barroso le président de la commission
européenne pervenche berès merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté l'invitation
d'europe hebdo c'est la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine d'ici là bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires